[Music]
my uh next guest tonight
is a writer and actor on are we there
yet right here on tbs and you can uh see
him thursday january 26th at 10 o'clock
p.m on russell simmons presents the
ruckus on comedy central please welcome
to very funny owen smith
[Music]
yeah
yeah
all right thank you
thank you
all right uh my name is owen i live in
new york
and uh i thank you all right i went to
occupy wall street every day yeah yeah
not for the reasons you're thinking uh i
went mainly because i loved hearing
white boys complaining about cops
beating them up for nothing
it was like music to my ears
hey white guy how's it going this cop
just stood me to the ground for freaking
nothing really wow
i never heard of such a thing
tell me more
i went every day i was snitching on
white boys hey cop just some white boys
doing good nothing over there you might
want to get them
right outside the drum circle right
there see something say something i see
that right there
welcome to the game yeah a lot's
happening man gay people can get married
in new york it's going to happen here
i'm so happy for them i'm happy uh but
here's who i feel sorry for with gay
marriage um the one gay dude who didn't
really want to get married
this is ruining his whole thing
when it's illegal he's winning you know
he's like i want to marry you
but they won't let me
[Applause]
not anymore baby congratulations
[Music]
glitter glitter glitter glitter glitter
i bet when he got that news he was like
yeah
what straight dude wouldn't kill for
that same excuse
you know i would kill to be able to tell
my woman hey baby i want to marry you
make an honest woman out of you but it's
against the law
get up my damn self
skip out the room
yo marriage man you know it's the words
i do i don't like oh
i get married if they let me say i do my
best
that's all you can do is your best and
it's the vows too it should just be one
vowel they should just cut to the chase
let's just get to it like hey you love
him yeah yeah all right man uh you
promised
never to sleep with anybody else
i do my best
even the preacher be like good luck
many have tried because that's the only
vow anybody cares about there's other
vows in there right honor
cherish nobody cares about those you
have never heard hey man what happened
to you and tina
she stopped cherishing me man
you were like i understand when she's
sleeping with somebody else now brother
you not hearing me the cherishment was
not there
and don't get me started on honor
i just want people to make it i want
couples to stay together you know what i
mean but it's rough every time i turn
around straight people we're getting
divorced you know and my mom told me
years ago she said true love lasts for
two years
after that it's hard work
then she just walked away i'm like i'm
seven why are you telling me that
[Music]
ask your father dang
but you know what else only lasts two
years
cell phone contracts
what if they figured us out you know
what i mean like i've left tons of women
you know i mean i've look i'll break up
with you if you sneeze wrong
but i will not leave sprint
i have been committed to them for over
16 years
if me and sprint had a kid they'd be
looking at colleges right now
i wish marriage was like that two-year
deal i'll sign up for that everybody can
make that and if you make it for two you
just renew the contract
hey baby we made it hey glitter glitter
glitter
so you wanna go another two
you sure you tried to stab me last week
all right let me call the people then
hey yo what's up it's me
yeah we made it yeah uh huh yeah we're
gonna go with number two
what i'm eligible for upgrades
thank you so much
thank you
thank you
hey ellen
that's great thank you thank you so much
very funny owen smith
[Applause]